secretary blinken left Beijing without
achieving a major U.S goal president Xi
Jinping still has not agreed to open
contact between the U.S and Chinese
militaries cut off since August the U.S
is concerned that a series of
provocative actions by China's military
like this fighter jet buzzing a U.S
surveillance aircraft in the South China
Sea raised the risk of miscalculation
more regular engagement regular
communication so that they understand
what we're doing and not doing Espionage
is also a top concern China expanded a
listening Post in nearby Cuba in 2019 to
surveil the U.S taking steps over the
past couple of years diplomatically
wherever we've seen China trying to
create that kind of presence we've been
in there pushing back against it and
we've had some success in doing that
this is nothing new